Ufo, Ufo.
Das Podcast UFO mit Florentin Will und Stefan Tietze. Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo. Ich muss meine ein bisschen erschrocken, weil plötzlich ein sehr lautes Geräusch drin war. Aber herzlich willkommen zum Podcast UFO mit Flore Flo und Wil und Stefan Tietze. Vielen Dank an Florian für das Intro. Vielen Dank für das fantastische Intro. Wir freuen uns immer weiter über jede gerne eingesendete Botschaft an uns. Aber nur gerne eingesendete. Ungerne eingesendete nehmen wir nicht gerne an. Und wir merken das schon, wenn ihr 1 zu 1 Garagebandloops copy-pasted und uns schickt. Wir kennen das schon. Ja, oder uns einfach einen Song von Britney Spears schickt, das merken wir auch, wir sind ja nicht gescheuert. Wir kennen auch Toxic, wir waren 1998. Wir kennen Songs, wir kennen Lieder, wir kennen Hits, wir kennen die grossen Kassenschlager, wir kennen sie alle. Wir sind drin. Ihr merkt, ich bin ein bisschen krank, dafür müssen Sie mich entschuldigen, ich habe auch ein anderes Mikro in der Hand. Aber es ist, ich hatte das Gefühl... Ich habe so ein achtiger Jahre Moderatoren-Intro in der Hand. Wir haben uns heute unterhalten, ich glaube so vielleicht zehn Minuten lang, und ich hatte das Gefühl, du wurdest während dieser Unterhaltung krank. Du startest, du kamst in den Raum, du warst gut drauf, du hattest Bock, du hast gesagt, ey komm, ich muss dir was erzählen, ich habe ein paar gute Ideen. Setz dich hin und ich merke, wie du minütlich einfach die Nase kommt raus, irgendwie immer nasaler, irgendwie immer mehr Schleim im Gesicht. Und ich merke einfachke einfach, wie du da niedergehst. Und ich war mir sehr alt dafür, dass du da stirbst. Es war ein sehr anstrengendes Gespräch, immer dieses ... Du warst ja auch in so einer, du warst beim Neo-Magazin, warst in so einer Vor-der-Sendung-Aufregung und hast nicht zugehört, hast aufs Handy, warst abgelenkt, die Sätze musste man wiederholen Und dann habe ich nach und nach abgebaut halt irgendwann. Aber jetzt geht es mir wieder schlecht. Ach, wird schon, wird schon. Bei mir ist es ein komischer Tag. Man findet ja manchmal Dinge auf seinem Schuh und fragt sich, wo kommt das her, wo war ich unterwegs, wo komme ich her? Und dann kennt man diesen Horrorfilm, Blick nach oben, dieses, es tropft doch von der Decke, oder nicht? Ja, ich hatte heute Karamell auf meinem Schuh. Ja. Karamell, schön
klebriges Karamell. Ich weiß,
ich kann mir beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen, wo
das herkommt. Ich weiß nicht, wann es auf
meinen Schuh gekommen ist. Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
welche Tiere mittlerweile durch unsere Innenstädte
laufen, frei, dass sie sowas
hinterlassen. Ich weiß auch nicht, warum es nicht an der
Sohle des Schuhs ist, sondern obendrauf.
Aber wie, wie, es sieht nicht aus wie Karamell. Doch, das ist Karamell. Aber es sieht nicht aus wie Furcht. Es sieht einfach aus wie Hunde. Nein, nein, nein, es ist dunkles, klebriges Karamell. Hundedöns klebt nicht. Und das klebt. Und ich kann mir beim besten Willen nicht erklären... Aber du hast schon selbstbewusst reingefasst vorher, ne? Ich habe selbstbewusst, ich habe einfach reingefasst, ich habe auch den Geschmackstest gemacht. Ich wusste, dass ich da jetzt durch muss. Das wissen ja viele nicht. Erst der Geschmackstest, dann der Geruchstest. Richtig. Machen viele falsch. Was sich durch Schmecken nicht umbringt, kann sich durchs Riechen auch nicht umbringen. What doesn't kill you makes it stronger. Ja, what doesn't smell you makes you feel good. Es ist einfach, und ich weiß auch, du blickst einfach anders auf dein Leben, du merkst deine Füsse für ein eigenes Leben. Ja. Ich weiß nicht, was meine Füsse den ganzen Tag machen. Das ist so, man kommt nach Hause und hat sich schon wochenlang nicht mehr mit seinem Onkel unterhalten. Und man so, jetzt erzähl mal. Und ich habe das Gefühl, bei den Füssen ist es ähnlich. Du kommst nach Hause und du denkst dir, was habt ihr eigentlich so den ganzen Tag gemacht? Wo wart ihr unterwegs? Es ist eine andere Welt. Ich habe neue Schuhe mir gekauft, vor ein paar Wochen, weiße Schuhe, und tatsächlich sind die mir zu weiß gewesen die ganze Zeit. Weil ich finde, diese Schuhe, die ich mir gekauft habe, die sind Investitionen in die Zukunft. Die sind nämlich, die muss man erst auslatschen. Und mittlerweile haben sie schon so einen gewissen ausgelatschten Turnschuhcharakter, finde ich, den mag ich ganz gern. Ich finde aber, die Zeit ist nur der optimale Zeitpunkt, sie haben noch nicht genug gereift, würde ich mal sagen. Und tatsächlich war das Erste, was ich gemacht habe, als ich mich entschieden habe für dieses Exemplar, war ich mit den alten Schuhen genommen und bin auf den Schuhen rumgetrampelt, um die ein bisschen eingetragen zu machen. Und einfach um den alten Schuhen zu sagen, wer jetzt der Chef ist, einfach so, wer jetzt einfach das Sagen im Haus hat. Nein, ich habe die alten Schuhe genommen, um auf denen rumzutrampeln. Ach so, ich dachte, du bist mit den neuen Schuhen auf den alten rumgetrampelt. Nein, ich habe quasi den alten Schuhen erlaubt, den neuen Chef zu sein. Okay, es ist ein merkwürdiges Übergangsretort. Das ist ja so, wenn du als Kind ein neues Haustier haben möchtest, du hast so einen langweiligen Hasen und willst einen Hund. Rammler. Und dann sagen aber die Eltern, du hast schon einen Hasen, dann musst du als Kind halt irgendwie den Hasen tottreten. Du musst halt irgendwie was überlegen. Weil in diesem merkwürdigen Bild, was du so aufgemacht hast, war dein Hase mit so weiss, und ich habe dem alten der Schildkröte erlaubt, nochmal auf dem Hasen rumzulaufen, damit der Hase eingelaufen ist. Es ist ein sehr merkwürdiges Bild. Naja, und tatsächlich habe ich die Türen ein bisschen dreckig gemacht, absichtlich, weil sie mit so weiss waren. Ja. Und jetzt sind sie schon besser, weil ich sie ein paar Wochen trage.
Aber auch hier kommen Flecken her, wo ich nicht weiss, wie kommen die da hin.
Aber wie hast du sie dreckig gemacht?
Was hast du gemacht, um aktiv zu sagen, jetzt mache ich meine Schuhe dreckig?
Alte Schuhe haben ja so einen gewissen Dreckfilm unter sich.
Ach so, es geht ja um die Sohle.
Es geht mir um die Sohle.
Ich denke mal, wenn du sagst Schuh, denke ich gar nicht an die Sohle.
Für mich sind das zwei unterschiedliche Welten. Der Schuh ist so die Kuppel oben drüber. Ich bin mit meinem alten Schuh darauf rumgetreten. Wie hast du dir das vorgestellt? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß nur, dass es schwer ist. Ich hätte merken, würde ich es bemerken. Es ist aber schwer, Dinge authentisch dreckig zu machen. Es war bei Drehs oft so, dass ich ein frisches Kostüm anhatte, aber in der Szene sollte man dreckig sein, irgendwie ein Höhlenmensch oder sowas. Und dann hieß es, jetzt mach dich mal dreckig. Und dann gehst du halt irgendwie raus und gehst auf eine Baustelle und wälzt dich da einfach im Staub rum. Und dann siehst du auch aus wie jemand, der sich absichtlich dreckig gemacht hat. Und nicht wie jemand... Ja, das ist schon schwierig, das stimmt. Deswegen ist Ausstattung und Kostüm auch wirklich ein wahnsinnig Unterschied, dass die Parten... Es ist ein Knochenjob und wir möchten hier nochmal 14 Schweigeminuten für das Ausstattungs- und Requisitendepartment abhalten. Ihr macht echt einen gutener. Tolle Anerkdote von Bo Burnham, der in seinem Film Eighth Grade die Szene geschrieben hat, dass dieses kleine Mädchen, was den YouTube-Tunnel auch hat und Probleme hat mit sich selber und mit ihrem Selbstbewusstsein, die hat sich so Motivationssprüche auf Post-its geschrieben. Das macht sie schon lange, deswegen hat sie eine große, vor allem Spiegel, quasi eine grosse Umrandung mit Post-its, wo so, du schaffst das, du bist der Boss, get out there, put yourself out there, so Sprüche draufgeschrieben hat und halt mit teilweise sehr alten Post-its. Das Problem ist, es gibt halt, die Ausstattung musste halt diesen Raum ausstatten mit alten Post-its und Post-its sehen immer neu aus. Das stimmt. Weil die kleben halt auch nur begrenzt lang. Ja. Und irgendwann fallen die so ab und lösen sich ab.
Und da haben die das, und lösen sich ab.
Das war ein Ausstattungsehepaar,
die hat diese Motivationssprüche einfach ein halbes Jahr
vor Drehbeginn bei sich in der Wohnung aufgehangen.
Das war der Trick.
Und die ist jetzt Millionärin, weil sie einfach gesagt hat,
ich schmeisse meinen Job als Ausstatterin hin,
ich geh go out there, you go girl, you get them,
und ich bin da hingegangen und hab eine Gehaltserhöhungung gewollt und am Ende waren alle pleite und sie war reich. Du willst deine Mitarbeiter nicht zu sehr motivieren. Nee, genau. Und die hatten dann wirklich zu Hause diese Post-its und haben die dann ein Set gebracht und haben die aufgeklebt. Und wie man es von guten, gebrauchten Post-its erwartet, die schon ein bisschen länger hängen, lösen sich ab. Ja, die knicken sich, die biegen sich so rein nach oben. Die biegen sich, die sind geknittert. Ist doch kein Problem. Ja, Post-its sind nämlich nicht geil. Ist aber auch eine gute Ausrede, wenn du zu Hause gefunden wirst mit dem peinlichen Wandtattoo und dann sagst du ja, ist ja scheiße und dann sagst du ja, ich bin Ausstatterin und das ist in einem halben Jahr noch in einem Film gebraucht im Hintergrund. Das ist eine sehr gute Ausrede, das stimmt schon. Das stimmt. Ich wollte dieses Wochenende, habe hier angekündigt, zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben Karneval feiern. Zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben, ich hatte alles bereit. Ja, Thais hat dir extra beraten zu deinen Kostümen, was ist es geworden? Ich möchte es nicht sagen. Am Ende hatte ich aber alles bereitgestellt. Es gab das Kostüm, ich war bereit hinzugehen, ich hätte es schon abends vorbereitet. Und dann wurde ich so krank. Ich werde nicht so häufig krank, ich werde einmal im Jahr krank vielleicht, da habe ich so einen leichten Schnupfen. Aber ich hätte wirklich so Fieberträume, wie man einige, und das ist schon schlimm. Und irgendwie, es war wirklich eine Nacht, man kennt das ja von Fieberträumen, die sind sehr wild und sehr assoziativ und oft nicht zu fassen. Und irgendwie war mein Traum die ganze Zeit, also waren sämtliche Gedanken des Tages halt verpackt in einer Welt. Und diese Welt hat mein Kopf entschieden, musste sein, Wien, wo eine Glaskuppel drüber ist. So, und dann war alles, alle anderen Ideen und Gedanken und Dinge, die ich verarbeiten musste offensichtlich, mussten in diesem Kontext spielen. Wien mit der Glaskuppel über sich. Und meine ganze Nacht war wahnsinnig anstrengend. Es war wie so, ich gucke mir selber bei einem schlechten Improabend zu. So, und wo der Kopf sich das lustige Impro-Spiel überlegt hat, okay, aber alle Settings sind jetzt in Wien mit einer Glaskuppel drüber, ha, ha,, hahaha. So, und dann die ganze Nacht, es waren zwölf Stunden Auftritt, wo ich mir mit dem Kopf zugucken konnte, was er jetzt damit anstellt. Und es war die Qual. Und die Ideen werden immer weniger und werden immer enger, und man merkt, das Brainstorming führt zu nichts. Das Brainstorming führt zu nichts, nee. Und das war wirklich so, fühlt sich so eine Febertraumnacht anfäll finde ich. Wir sind schlechtes Impro-Theater. Ich mir selber zugucken beim Jetzt hol die Pferde rein, hol die Pferde rein, hol die Pferde rein.
Das war wirklich ganz normal.
Du hast schon den Mantel an und sitzt schon in der ersten Reihe, bist schon so halb aufgestanden und so.
Ich war am Sprung. Ich war seit Minute eins, habe ich gedacht, ich werde hier nicht alt.
Aber hast du gemerkt, dass es ein Traum ist? Wusstest du, dass es ein Traum ist?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es ein Traum ist. Die ganze Zeit.
Aber ich komme nicht raus, wusste ich auch. Und ich hatte auch nichts besseres vor. In der Nacht hast du selten besseres vor. Du merkst, es ist ein Traum, das ist auch nicht das Gefühl, jetzt zum Sport, nee, es ist nachts. Oder jetzt. Stimmt, du willst eigentlich gar nicht aufwachen. Eigentlich ist ein schlechter Traum das Schlimmste, was es gibt, weil du willst nicht aufwachen, du willst aber auch den Traum nicht ertragen. Ja, ja. Und das hast du schon seit Karneval gemacht. Krank im Weggelegen habe ich und mir selber beim Ideenfinden für Wien mit einer Glaskuppel. Ja, nee, das war mein Karneval, ja. Aber dann ist mir aufgefahren, wie geil es ist, krank zu sein. Ja. Den ganzen Tag, für mich ist der einzige Zeitpunkt im Jahr, wo ich von mir selber rechtfertigen kann, nichts zu tun. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich muss jetzt irgendwas machen. Entweder muss ich mich weiterbilden mit einem Buch oder mit einer Serie oder so, was für mein Buch tun. Oder ich muss zumindest Sport machen oder keine Ahnung, irgendwas machen, was mir was bringt. Und ich kann nicht nichts tun. Stell dir vor, der Tod, der schwarze Tod, die Seuche im Mittelalter geht um sich und du hast sie halt nicht. Und alle flacken rum und machen nichts und du, ah hier, hilf doch bei den Leichen, mir geht es aber auch ein bisschen schlecht. Ach so, du hast auch die Pässe. Ich kriege es auch langsam. Ja, vielleicht und alle liegen rum. Ich habe schon so ein ungutes Gefühl, so ein flaues Gefühl im Magen. Du gehstst im Magen hier. Ein Hypochonder während der schwarzen Pässe, einfach so am Bein. Und alle so, ja, ist das Bein wirklich so schlimm? Ja, ich habe so ein Ziehen im Nacken und so, das ist eigentlich keine Symptome. Ist auch alles schlecht. War eine Scheißzeit einfach, es war eine Scheißzeit. Aber hättest du das nicht einfach irgendwie in dein Kostüm integrieren können? Ich gehe als kranker Mensch. Einfach, du gehst als kranker? Da ist dann so ein Tropf oder so und so ein Verband um Kopf oder sowas. Das finde ich auch nicht so schlecht. Ich gehe als kranker. Die Idee bin ich nicht gekommen. Ich hasse Karneval und ich war das erste Mal in meinem Leben in Köln in Karneval zur Karnevalzeit. Und ich kann erfolgreich berichten, ich habe es überlebt. Ich habe es überlebt, ich bin durchgekommen. Ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt bei mir, aber bei mir ist dieses Jahr der Twist gekommen. Ich glaube, es ist meine, weil ich genug Jahre, fünf Jahre in Köln und weil ich finde es billig zu sagen, der Karneval, ich hasse Karneval. Ja, Karneval ist vielseitig, Karneval ist nicht nur das Klischeehafte, man sich aus Sümern und säuft. Ja, es kommt darauf an, also ich glaube, wenn man sich nicht aktiv beteiligt, nimmt man Karneval nochmal anders wahr, als wenn man sich beteiligt. Und das macht, was einem Spaß macht darin. Bei mir ist es wirklich so, ich wohne an einer der, glaube ich, Karnevalhauptstrassen. Und es waren einfach vor allem nicht dieses ständige Gekotze und Gegröle, daran gewöhnt man sich irgendwann, aber diese komplett willkürlichen und random Umzüge. Also wirklich, ich war irgendwie, glaube ich, um acht Uhr abends, habe ich DSA gespielt, Rollenspiel, Pen and Paper, sitzt da und ihr seid jetzt gerade in der Burg und es ist Nacht und der Feind lauert vor den Burgmauern und okay, wir klettern wieder liegen. Denn wenn der Trömmel schieht, dann stamm mal Parade. Also wirklich klischeehaft die Parade. Rum-da-da-dam-dam, rum-da-da-dam-dam, ging an deiner Haustür vorbei. Und ich so, sorry Leute, ich brauche kurz einen Moment. Hey, ich spiele hier DSA. Leute, ich habe auf Schleichen gewürfelt, sorry, könnt ihr kurz einfach... Denn wenn der Trömmel... Auch jeder Karnevalssong beginnt mit Denn wenn der Trömmel-Sche-Jade. Ja, und der schlimmste an so einem Spielmann-Zug-Umzug sind immer die Nachzügler. Der eigentliche Zug ist ja durch, aber dann kommen noch so die Nachzügler.
Und der eine Typ, der so ein Becken hat und so und er ewig lang und das ist einfach fucking nervig.
Und auch so abends, ich raff auch nicht, was es soll. Die grosse Bassdrum ist oft ein bisschen zu langsam, weil die haben auch meistens zu tragen.
Das stimmt, ja.
Die spielen auch langsamer und irgendwie Doppler-Effekt. Es ist eine absolute Katastrophe. Und es ist völlig random. Und tatsächlich hat es einige Tage, das werden vielleicht einige Karnevalsgänger bestätigen können, es hat viel geregnet und ich bin ein Arschloch, ich bin ein schadenfrohes Arschloch. Du hast einen Regentanz aufgeführt, dann führst du den Regentanz auf. Und die hatten alle keinen Spaß und hatten alle ihre dummen kleinen Klopfer in der Tasche und ihren dummen scheiß Alkohol und waren alle nass und ich saß an meinem Fenster und sagte, he he he, das habt ihr jetzt davon, dass ihr soziale Interaktion und Anschluss an die Gesellschaft sucht. Und alle wurden nass. Ich wirf mit einem W6 auf Regen. Und alle sind sich vorbeigelaufen in ihren lustigen satirischen Kostümen, aber mit so einem Regenponcho drüber. Das war sehr lustig wieder. Da hat ein neongrünes Regenponcho über seinem Lichtschwert. Ja, vorgestern war jemand als Mozart. Ich weiß nicht, ob es Mozart war, aber jemand in einem barocken Kostüm, in so einem klassistischen barocken Kostüm. Ja, ich bin Signorelli, verdammt nochmal, nicht Mozart. Ich bin Salieri, hast du gar nichts gelernt. Naja, und der hat eine Jack-Wolft-Jakke drüber getragen. Aber er hatte ein total schickes barockes Kostüm. Und dann denke ich mir, die hatten Jacken. Du hättest zumindest all in gehen können und daran denken können, dass es Februar ist, März, und dann zumindest nochmal eine Jacke drüberziehen können. Weil dein Kostüm hat eine Jacke. Gut, wenn du jetzt als Superman gehst, dass der jetzt nicht einen Anurag überzieht und einen Superman Anurag hat, das ist mir schon auch klar. Oder beim Tyrannosaurus Rex macht es auch nicht Sinn, dann nochmal drüber irgendwie die Alpha Industries Jacke drüber zu tragen, macht keinen Sinn, aber beim Barockkostüm Mozart, ja, aber dann füllen wir auf, was hatten die denn für Jacken, habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Die hatten so eingewachste Mäntel, glaube ich, das kann man, bei DSA zum Beispiel kann man das kaufen, weil da heißt dann auch immer, oh, wir gehen jetzt irgendwo hin, wo es regnet, was kann ich kaufen und dann sagt der Meister halt, keine Ahnung, Wachs, Mäntel, was hat man, da muss ich irgendeinen Scheiss aus den Fingern saugen und keine Ahnung. Aber es ist, das ist, eigentlich muss man sein Kostüm immer so bauen, dass man auch im Regen damit bestehen kann. Du musst eigentlich immer schon von Anfang an in der Konzeptphase alleine schon mitdenken, was kann ich machen, Kokowai, ja, Pokémon als Palme, du hast oben noch so Palmblättern, die dich schützen vor Regen. Denk einen Schritt weiter. Du bist ein menschliches Golfwagen, Golfkart. Denk weiter.
Okay, ich verrate doch, was ich sein. Ja, bitte. Ich war ein bisschen um, weil du so Witze gemacht hast und so, aber es passt halt zu mir und ich war spät dran, als habe ich mich für Han Solo entschieden. So, und aber das Clevere daran ist, bei Herrn Solo kannst du, wenn es kalt ist, einfach zum Hoth-Kostüm wechseln, ziehst du dir einfach eine, und es ist lustigerweise ja einfach eine Winterjacke mit Fell. Die sind jetzt wieder total modern. Das stimmt. Und die Brille, die die aufhaben, ist eine Skibrille. Es ist einfach eine Skibrille. Das ist eigentlich ganz gut. Ich dachte, du hast doch den ATS-D genommen und kannst dann wirklich mit so einem Dach drüber einfach durch die Gegend stelzen. Wäre perfekt gewesen. Nee, das konnte man, nee, da so viel Arbeit wie da reinstecken. Aber ganz merkwürdig fand ich diese Kostüme, die nicht irgendwas darstellen, sondern du hast so einen Grünanzug, wo draufsteht Hello und Karneval und das Wappen von Köln, das steht da drauf. Also die verkleiden sich am Karneval als Karneval. Und man denkt sich so, ist das jetzt so ein Metagag? Ist das so ein abstraktes Ding, zu sagen, ich gehe selbst als der Karneval an Karneval? Es ist super merkwürdig, es hat mich komplett verwirrt zurückgelassen. Die Fallkostüme ist ja einfach diese Ring Ringelshirts, zumindest hier in Köln diese weissroten, die ich auch nicht genau verstehe. Ist das dann ... Also, das machen aber die Hardcore-Karnevalisten. Muss ich mal sagen, ist Hardcore, müsstet ihr nicht krasse Kostüme haben? Nee, die Hardcore-Karnevalisten gehen dann zurück und sagen, das ist wie so, Star Wars, richtige Star Wars-Fans tragen kein Star Wars-Merch. Die richtigen Karnevalisten verkleiden sich nicht, die gehen dann zum Ringel-Shirt. Aber ich glaube, Karneval hat ja auch mal ganz anders angefangen. Ich glaube, generell jeder Feiertag läuft Gefahr, in einen Kostümfeiertag zu kippen. Halloween, ja, da wurden früher Hexen verbrannt oder so und irgendjemand sagt so, ja, ich bin aber Mirapla. Und so, ja, okay. Und dann irgendwann wird so ein Kostüm. Und ich glaube, Karneval ist auch was anderes. Und ich glaube, wenn wir nicht höllisch aufpassen, ist Pfingsten. Mark my words. Wenn wir jetzt nicht irgendwie die Weichen richtig stellen. Wenn irgendwann Pfingsten jemand sagt so, ich habe jetzt aber schon mein, keine Ahnung, Daenerys Targaryen Outfit habe ich jetzt schon gekauft, trage ich halt ein Pfingsten, und dann haben wir ein fucking Problem. Wenn die uns unser Pfingsten verkleiden, rastig aus. Wirklich. Aber erst kommt noch Ostern, macht immer keine Sorgen. Erst kommt Ostern, dann kommt Weihnachten. Ostern ist sehr, glaube ich, aber Pfingsten kann kippen. Pfingsten kann wirklich kippen. Ja, nee. Ich finde es zumindest gut, dass Halloween bei uns, da hat man sich zumindest entschieden, okay, wir bleiben bei gruseligen Kostümen, okay? Wir als Landdeutschland haben gesagt, wir bleiben bei gruseligen Kostümen. Ja. Gruselig. Das ist die Idee. Motto gruselig. In den USA ist da, die haben gar keine Grenzen mehr, da ist einfach alles erlaubt. Gut, da ist ja auch gerade, aber was da gerade los ist. Aber die ziehen sich an, das ist ja deren Karneval quasi. Das stimmt. Die ziehen sich da einfach an, was sie wollen. Wir haben eigentlich mehr Verkleidungsfeiertage als die USA. Wir haben Karneval und Halloween. Und Halloween, ja. Doppelt so viele quasi. Nee, irgendwannann, Pfingsten kommt noch, und irgendwann haben wir mehr Tage, an denen wir uns verkleiden, als normale Tage, und spätestens dann, wir brauchen Feiertagsminister, wir brauchen ein Ministerium, das einfach da mal einhakt und sagt, Freunde, so geht's nicht weiter. Es muss ein bisschen in Ordnung reinkommen. Es gibt so weirde Trends gerade, die 80er-Jahre kommen ja gerade so ein bisschen zurück, oder manchmal auch die 90s bei Schuhen zum Beispiel. Und man freut sich manchmal auf der Straße, habe ich mich beim Karneval, wenn ich manchmal gefragt, ist es jetzt ein Kostüm oder ist es wirklich ernst gemeint? Das war nicht schon interessant dieses Jahr. Ja, es ist schwierig. Viele so 80er-Jahre-Jacken, wo ich sage, das können wir noch so tragen. Vor allem, ich hasse Schuhe und ich habe ja so Birkenstockschlappen. Und immer wenn ich nur einkaufen gehe, ziehe ich die an, egal was ich habe. Normalerweise bin ich barfuss in meiner Wohnung und ziehe die dann an und dann ist es halt immer so ein bisschen bescheuert, gerade wenn es regnet und kalt ist und du bist der einzige Depp mit Birkenstocksandalen. Aber an Karneval dachte ich mir, kein Problem und ich wurde trotzdem dumm angeguckt. Ich wurde trotzdem dumm angeguckt, dann stehst du halt in der Schlange und der vor dir tritt sich um und dann so ein Blick so und ich hab Socken, du hast keine Socken.
Weil ich hab mir gestern eine Erkältungsbad gekauft.
Bad?
Eine Erkältungsbad.
Ja?
Ja. Und mir war es so unangenehm, ich weiß gar nicht warum eigentlich, weil mir war das im DM, so unangenehm ein Erkältungsbad zu kaufen, weil ich dachte, bitte lass es nicht irgendwie jugendliche Karnevalisten vor mir oder hinter mir sein, die das irgendwie
kommentieren, dass ich mir jetzt ein Erkältungsbad kaufe.
Schön mit Eukalyptus, Minze.
Das will ich ja Anti-Karneval einfach.
Erkältungsbad ist, glaube ich, das genaue Gegenteil
von Karneval. Ja, das Gegenteil von Karneval dann.
Weil ich dachte, wenn ich schon nicht feiere,
dann noch wenigstens gar nicht feiern.
Ja, und dann war so eine
schlecht sehende Oma hinter mir und dachte dachte ich mir, yes, geil, yes, danke. Und dann habe ich mir das Erkältungsbad gegönnt. Das war wirklich toll. Kann ich auch nur empfehlen. Zwanzig Minuten lang, kochend heiß, schön das mit Eukalyptus und Minze, und es ist so grün, und es ist ganz mit Schaum, und es macht man ein paar Kerzen an, macht man sich, guckt schön. Du machst schön Kerzen an? Ein paar Kerzen an, Duftkerzen. Wann machst du die an, bevor du ins Wasser gehst? Ich mache keine Kerzen an. Ah, wusste ich. Daran erkennt man nämlich unerfahrene Bader. Kerzen? Du machst nicht. Nein, ich mache keine Kerzen an. Nur Baderanfänger machen Kerzen. Baderanfänger machen Kerzen. Ja, Baderanfänger, Baderexperten machen keine Kerzen. Die machen absolut viel. Ich habe echt lange nicht mehr gebadet, will ich nicht mehr. Bill Burr hat sich da auch immer lustig gemacht, dass man badet als Mann. Was ich sehr falsch fand. Baden ist grossartig. Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich glaube, das wäre die sicherste Situation, in der ich eine Kerze anmachen würde, weil ich wüsste, angenommen, die Kerze fällt jetzt runter und meine Kommode fängt an zu brennen. Ich sitze in einer Badewanne. Mir kann wirklich gar nichts passieren, oder? Du musst dann in diese Habachtstellung schon, weil manche Glieder hängen ja raus beim Baden, manchmal, nach dem Bierbades. Also musst du schnell mit dem Kopf untertauchen und die Wohnung immer noch beobachten beim Abbrennen. Ja, und du kannst ja so Wasser so rausspritzen, so wie im Schwimmbad. Aber wenn du wieder zurückgehend, dass du halb untergetaucht bist. Aber gibt es das nicht auch so bei einer Atombombe, dass man in die Badewanne soll oder so und sich zudecken soll, irgendwie sowas? Ich glaube, weil es ist dann auch scheißegal und dann kannst du auch in die Badewanne. Dann schlippst du wenigstens mit dem Funken hoffentlich noch. Dieses komische Startmikrofon, was du mir gegeben hast heute, es klebt. Es tut mir leid. Es ist widerlich. Und ich glaube, du willst, also, weil wir müssen heute ein bisschen improvisiert aufnehmen, weil das Neo Magazin Royale hat unsere Mikrofone geklaut für ihr tolles Gästespiel, deswegen muss Stefan mit einem Behelfsmikrofon Aushilfe nehmen, das ich gerade zusammengebaut habe. Du willst nicht wissen, warum das unten klebt. Warum klebt es? Es ist ein bisschen klebig unten, du willst wirklich nicht wissen, warum. Egal, was du dir vorstellst, ist besser als das, was es wirklich ist. Nicht im Ernst. Nicht im Ernst. Ignorier es einfach. Ich stelle mir das Schlimmes an vor. Egal, was du dir vorstellst, es ist noch schlimmer. Er riecht gerade an seiner Hand. Nee, Kleber riecht generell gut. Kleber? Kleber ist super. Also doch Kleber. Naja, wenn es klebrig ist. Naja, ich sag mal, gewisse Körperflüssigkeiten kleben auch rund. Ja. Das ist das Schlimmste, was ich mir vorstellen kann. Na, dann hast du noch einen Weg. Dann habe ich noch einen Weg. Du hast noch ein Stück vor dir. Nee, es funktioniert schon. Wien war da echt toll, muss man echt sagen. Das hat mich wieder nachhaltig beeindruckt, diese Stadt. Ja, ich bin da wahnsinnig gern. Wir haben so viel gelernt. Die Leute waren nett, wir haben viel einfach gelernt, viele neue Worte gelernt. Da möchte ich gerne alt werden. Ich habe echt überlegt, irgendwann mal eine Zweitwohnung in Wien wäre echt schon so ... Man ist da relativ schnell. Also ich habe vor allem erkannt, durch die ganze Tour jetzt, und jetzt auch jobbedingt oder so, muss man häufiger nach Berlin fliegen, wie einfach von meiner Wohnung bis zum Kölner Flughafen, ich habe es lächerlich strapaziert jetzt auch mal, weil ich dachte, jetzt probieren wir es mal aus, weil ich bin schnell am Flughafen. Und ich dachte mir so, wie spät muss ich los? Und dann wollte ich es auch mal wissen.
Ich muss eine dreiviertel Stunde vor Boarding, äh, vor Abflug da sein, äh, los. Sorry, ich komme nochmal rein. Eine dreiviertel Stunde nach Abflug von des Boardings Beginns anfangen zu denken, los zu. muss tatsächlich, ungefähr eine halbe Stunde vor Abflug kann ich entspannt los. Ich bin neun Minuten von Door-to-Door am Flughafen, und dann, da kenne ich mich aus, die Wege sind klar, die Wege sind kurz. Ja. Easy, wenn man mit Handgepäck fliegt und ich noch einchecken muss, easy. Es ist schon krass, aber ich habe echt mittlerweile ein schlechtes Gewissen beim Fliegen. Es ist natürlich auch wegen Umwelt und sowas, aber jedes Element an dem Erlebnis Fliegen
sagt mir, der Mensch sollte nicht fliegen.
Das ist zu krass, das ist zu abgefahren.
Du hast eine fucking Schwimmweste dabei.
Und dann denkst du dir einfach, das ist nicht, also nicht nur, dass der Mensch fliegt.
Er sollte auch nicht schwimmen. Er ist hier so doppelt ausserhalb von seinem Element. Er ist nicht nur nicht am Boden, wo er hingehört, er ist potenziell auch im Wasser, wo er auch nicht hingehört. In dem Flugzeug ist der Mensch komplett aus seiner Comfortzone. Draußen... Warum nicht Flügel eigentlich? Warum geben die einem nicht so Schwimmen Flügel erstmal? Ich weiss es nicht Entschuldigung, sorry. Ich weiß es nicht, aber es ist einfach ausserhalb des Flugzeugs, es ist minus 40 Grad, du würdest sofort sterben, es ist viel zu hoch. Na, nicht sofort. Ja, aber relativ schnell. Es ist einfach, und auch diese ganze Anstrengung und dann mit den Turbinen und dann haben die so Rotorblätter und ich denke mir einfach, das ist zu krass. Also jetzt fang nicht mit Raumfahrt an, aber ich habe einfach wirklich ein schlechtes Gewissen, weil ich mir denke, ich gehöre hier einfach nicht hin. Das ist zu viel Aufwand. Nein, in meiner Flugsimulatorphase. So ein riesiger Metallvogel, der fliegt nur wegen mir in die Luft und denkst dir, wie schwer das Teil ist und dann müssen die ganzen Leute das da ziehen und ein Paket da irgendwo reintun. Und ich denke mir, das ist zu krass einfach.
Die Bahn fährt eh.
So, und ob ich mich da jetzt reinknämmen. Die Bahn ist auch eine Ingenieursmeisterleistung. Ja, aber das ist eine Raupe, die auf dem Boden kriecht. Und wenn du da irgendwo, ja, wenn die, die fährt dann nicht ins Wasser, aber da hältst du halt mal in Hamm Westfalen, da willst du auch nicht sein. Da hängst du da ab. So, ob ich jetzt im Atlantik rumschwimme mit einer blinkenden Lampe, bis mich jemand wie so ein Helikopter zieht und mich wie so ein Elefanten dann irgendwo auf Westland absetzt, oder ob ich jetzt dann in Hamburg drei Stunden rumstehe und auf die nächste Bahn warte. Das wird schon nichts passieren, du stirbst ja nicht sofort. Du kannst rutschen, im Idealfall kannst du rutschen. Das stimmt. Ich meine, beim letzten Flug sass ich neben zwei jüngeren Damen, so vierzehn oder sowas, und es war vielleicht ihr erster Flug, war irgendwie so ein Klassenausflug oder so, und die haben wirklich auf der Startbahn, haben die sich ihre Hände gehalten gegenseitig, und die hatten so Angst, und als das Flugzeug Gas gegeben hat, haben die halt einfach geschrien, einfach wirklich aus vollem Leib, wirklich, als würden sie gerade abgestochen werden. Ich liebe es. Und in dem Moment, du sitzt daneben und dann wird es direkt mit vier G nach hinten gedrückt, während die Schranke denkst du einfach, das ist zu krass, das gehört sich nicht, der Mensch ist zu weit gegangen. Leute, warum ist lassen? Und du wirklich einfach, sorry, es war auch Quatsch. Ich glaube, es braucht einen Mutigen, der einfach sagt, Leute, Flugverkehr für Menschen, wir haben es einfach übertrieben, wir waren zu gierig, es ist zu krass. Ich meine, damals, als man im Mittelalter so die Katapulte hatte und sich in Städte schießen konnte, da haben schon Leute gesagt, es ist nicht ein bisschen krass. Und dann Flugzeuge und wirklich, wenn du denkst, wenn 14-jährige Mädchen in Todesangst schreien, während wir dieses Verkehrsmittel benutzen, dann läuft hier irgendwas gehörig. Nein, ich glaube, Fliegen nimmt sich ein bisschen wichtig. Fliegen wird nämlich nie müde zu erwähnen, dass wir jetzt fliegen. Ja, aber man fliegt halt auch. Und deswegen diese Sicherheitsvorkehrung, ja, aber wir haben uns daran gewöhnt. Wir können fliegen seit wie vielen Jahren? Zwei? Wir haben Erfahrung. Und nee, und dann die Sicherheitseinweisungen, bei der Bahn kann auch so viel schief gehen. Ich würde sogar behaupten, dass statistisch gesehen bei Zugunglücken mehr Leute sterben als beim Flugverkehr. Mir geht es nicht um Sicherheit, mir geht es einfach um die Hybris zu sagen, wir machen das jetzt. Daher kommt das Geschreie halt, weil die am Anfang sagen, falls ihnen was passiert, hier erzählen wir ihnen nochmal, wie man die Sicherheitsgurte öffnet. So, wow. Wo man auch sagt, warum erzählst du uns das? Jeder weiß,
wie man einen Kurt öffnet. Jeder war
im Auto. Es ist auch einfach, weil es das modernste Verkehrsmittel
ist. Und wenn das nächste kommt,
die Röhre, dann ist Flug wieder, dann
passt Flug vielleicht. Vielleicht bin ich da einfach nur zu konservativ.
Und bis die Röhre kommt,
oder irgendwie der Teleporterraum oder
sowas. Ich habe mir wirklich überlegt, wie
das mit so Teleporterkammern wäre.
Dass man in den Flughafen, da gibt es dann so den
Teleporterflughafen und du gehst
rein und wirst dann halt nach Stuttgart gesappt
Vielen Dank. Ich habe mir wirklich überlegt, wie das mit so Teleporterkammern wäre. Dass man in den Flughafen, da gibt es dann so den Teleporterflughafen und du gehst rein und wirst dann halt nach Stuttgart gesäbt und dann wird dein Gepäck aufgesäbt, dann gibt es halt so ein kleineres und dann muss man da wie so durch diese Sicherheitstore rein, einer nach dem anderen weg und auf der anderen Seite wieder, ah Stefan, hey und dann trifft man sich wieder und dann ist man halt da. Ja, da ist dann, weil beim Fliegen bist du halt, du bist schneller da, aber du musst auch länger am Flughafen warten, du musst länger da sein. Vielleicht ist es beim Beamen auch so. Der hat so vier Stunden vor dem Zap da sein. Ja, und darfst vielleicht auch nichts essen zwei Stunden vorher und so. Das stimmt. Es hat andere Unbequemigkeiten, die musst du dann so über dich gehen lassen. Du musst dich besonders gut waschen, wenn du dich nicht wäscht, dann hast du vielleicht so eine,
weiss nicht, dann brennt sich das so ein.
Ja, aber dafür darfst du so viel Flüssigkeit mitnehmen, wie du willst.
Du hast einen fucking Fass Wein dabei,
kein Problem, roll's rein!
Ja, aber wenn irgendwas
Magnetisches in deinem Körper ist,
dann war's das.
Dann wird danach dein ganzes Körper magnetisch.
Und dann kommt es irgendwann zum 9-11
der Teleporters, weil dann irgendwie hat sich auch die Pyramide von Gizeh gebeamt. Und dann sagen sie auch, ja, dann lassen wir es jetzt auch. Oder dann kriegst du keine Sache, Wasser mehr trinken. Genauso wie, und das ist ja erstaunlich, haben wir völlig vergessen, Zeppeline. Haben wir nicht vergessen. Es gab, doch, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass du, wann hast du, nee, nee, vor wie langer Zeit hast du das letzte Mal an Zeppeline gedacht? Bitte was? Ich denke minütlich an Zeppeline. Gut, okay. Nee, ich habe vor allem vor drei Wochen oder so, mein Podcast wurde davon erzählt. Ja, vor drei Wochen. Da hast du mit Augen gerollt, weil ich schon wieder mit Zeppeline anfange. Nee, aber das ist schon eine Weile her. Es gab mal eine Zeit, in der man fest davon ausging, dass das Verkehrsmittel in Zukunft der Zeppeline ist. Und aus gutem Grund. Du fliegst bis viel schneller als ... Was soll doch passieren? Ja. Sagen Sie mir mal, mit einem skeptischen Blick da hinten, was soll mit diesem Riesen mit brennendem Gas, gefülltem Riesenballon passieren? Ja, aber das brennende Gas ist direkt über den Passagieren, oder? Brennbare Gas ist direkt über den Passagieren, weil sie sind umrundet von brennbarem Gas. Es gibt mehr brennbares Gas als Passagiere. Ja. Darf man rauchen in dem Zeppelin? Ja, klar. Keine weiteren Fragen. Und tatsächlich auf der Hindenburg gab es, wie viele Feuerzeuge gab es auf der Hindenburg? Keins, eins, eins. Eins, es gab eins, es gab einen speziellen Feuerzeugwächter und wenn du rauchen wolltest, es gab ein Raucherzimmer, dann musstest du zu dem gehen und sagen, zünd's mir an, weil die durften keine Feuerzeuge mit auf die Hindenburg nehmen. Und das heißt, es gab einen Special Guy, dessen Aufgabe es war, ein Feuerzeug in der Hand zu haben. Und auch nur einer durfte eine Gabel haben, weil wenn du mit einer Gabel in die Wand stehst, war auch auch alles kaputt. Und Mittagszeit war einfach ein Chaos, einfach kann ich jetzt mal die Gabel haben. Kann der Messertyp kommen, kann der Feuerzeugtyp kommen. Sie stochern seit drei Minuten im Käsekuchen, kann ich bitte die Gabel haben? Aber es gab extra Stäbchen-Typ für die asiatischen Mitflieger. Ja, aber ganz stumpfe Stäbchen, damit die nicht auf dem Weg gehen können. Gab es da eine Sicherheitsvorkehrung eigentlich, solche Sicherheitseinweisungen auf so einem Zeppelin? Ich glaube nicht. Wir haben keine Notausgänge, keine Gurte, aber auch dafür. Ja, das stimmt. Wir haben aber auch erst die Warnwesten weggelassen, weil wenn was passiert, sind wir ja nicht. Das tödliche Gas wird unseren Aufprall abfedern, machen Sie sich da überhaupt keine Sorgen, kein Problem. Aber tatsächlich, allein durch diese Katastrophe Hindenburg hat man einfach ein gesamtes Verkehrsmittel eingestampft. Einfach gesagt, machen wir nicht mehr. Auch Concorde hat man da gesagt, nö, machen wir nicht mehr. Obwohl, ich glaube, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, ob das alleine der Concorde die Schuld in die Schuhe zu schieben ist oder nicht vielleicht eher dem System dahinter und der Politik dahinter. Ich glaube, dass dasberschreitflugzeug an sich schon eine gute Idee ist.
Ja, auch Zeppelin ist an sich eine super Idee.
Nein, Zeppelin ist langsam viel zu viel Aufwand für wenig Leute.
Du hast drei Passagiere, aber dafür hast du wie drei Heißluftballon grosse Behälter mit Gas.
In zwei Tagen in New York mit einem Zeppelin.
Ja.
In zwei Tagen.
Und du ballerst mit so einer riesigen Gurke übers Meer. Wie geil ist das denn und du guckst runter. Aber da kommt ein Windstoß und dann, ja gut, die Flugzeuge sind fünf Wochen. Ja. Wir müssen einmal andersrum fliegen, weil der Wind hat leicht gedreht. Konzentrierst du dich jetzt auf die negativen Sachen. Ja, ich kann es ziemlich missen. Ich glaube, es ist einfach, ich glaube, es hätte die Welt repostiert. Wie landen Zeppelinen? Landen die so, also haben die so Anflugkurven wie so Flieger und landen die einfach knallhart? Ich glaube, da gibt es dann so einen Lasso-Mann am Boden, der muss dann so einen Lasso hochwerfen und dann ziehen. Ich glaube, das ist nicht so schwer, so einen Zeppelin zu ziehen einfach nach unten. Da müssen auch viele Pranks, da müssen Zeppelinen gezogen haben. Oh, ich schmeiß den Stein dagegen. So eine riesige Lupe. Mit den wilden Westen zu fliegen, wie die ganzen Lassos weich sind. Nicht das Lupenmuseum! So eine riesige Lupe einfach. Hä, hä, hä. Ach, Zeppeline. Ich weiß nicht. Was kommt als nächstes? Ist es der Teleporter, der Zapper? Ich weiß nicht, ob es der Zapper ist. Hyperloop ist ein Riesending.
Wobei ich auch nicht glaube, dass es eine gute Idee ist.
Ist das jetzt eigentlich ein Vakuumrohr und dann schießt man jemanden durch mit geringem Widerstand oder ist es einfach nur ein Rohr?
Ist es damit nicht einfach nur ein Rohr geworden? Ich glaube auch, dass Elon Musk massiv überschätzt ist.
Der Typ hat die Ideen, den hat die gleiche Idee wie Futurama.
Futurama kam 2003 raus und der Typ sagt jetzt, ja, wir bauen so ein Rohr.
Aber er hat auch die Idee von PayPal.
Dim dim dim dim dim dim dim dim dim dim dim dim dim Summer nights having a blast.
Summer lovin' happened so fast.
I met a girl crazy for me.
Met a boy.
Nee, ich hab dem Mann aus dem Hof gesungen.
Ich meine eigentlich das Futurama-Intro.
Ist mir schon klar? Klingt aber lustigerweise so wie der Anfang von Summer Night. Aber alles klingt bei dir so an wie der Anfang von Summer Night. Letztes ist ein Krankenwagen und ist vorbeigefahren und du Summer Lovin' und der war wirklich schwer verletzt, Stefan. Ja, Summer Lovin'. Ja. Happens so fast. It does. Ist das Intro von Pew-Drama nicht einfach Smash Like Teen Spirit? Ja. Nein.
Nee, das ist, das gab es auch bei Donkey Konga, das ist... Donkey Konga? Ah, mir liegt es auf der Zunge! Den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den Was ist das Team Spirit? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Stefan! Das ist ein anderer Song, aber ich weiss nicht, wie der heisst, nicht September, sondern ... September. Das ist auch ein bisschen Vengaboys, ne? Vengaboys. Ich weiss nicht, wo ich gerade bin, es tut mir leid. Ich weiß, Sie wollen alles für Drama-Intoieren, aber ich komme gerade nicht auf den Song. Irgendwie sowas. Warte, warte, warte, warte. Es gab bestimmt oft Komponisten, die bei der Uraufführung gesagt haben, warte, warte, warte, warte, sag's nicht, nicht sagen, shit, was war's denn? Ist es wirklich mal passiert, dass irgendein Musiker einfach das Stück nicht mehr eingefallen ist und er vor nach fünf Minuten das Konzert abbrechen musste? Ja, das war vor der Erfindung der Noten, glaube ich. Davor hat man einfach gesagt, das erkenne ich aber auch lustigerweise von meinen Gitarrenabenden, weil ich selten meine berühmten Gitarrenabende teilweise monatelang in einem Loop gefangen habe. Ja, das hatte ich aber auch oft bei Stimme. Weil ich habe irgendwann aufgehört, nach Noten zu spielen, weil wenn man nicht vom Blatt lesen kann, irgendwann hast du es drin. Weißt du, irgendwann kannst du es so. Ich weiss ganz genau, was du meinst. Und dann bist du irgendwann in so Coda-Dingen gefahren. Genau, Coda Alphine. Und dann bist du sein Lübius. Das kenne ich auch beim Gesangssortag, ich kenne das auch, wenn man so klassisches Stücke hat und irgendwann kommt man dann ins Ende. Oder halt nicht, dann bist du wieder in der Strophe. Es ist Glück. Und dann der begleitete Pianist dann auch, fuck you. Irgendwann hat der Musiklehrer Schweissasperlen auf der Stirn und greift ein und nach 14 Minuten immer dasselbe so. Ja, danke an Stefan für dieses schöne Lied.
Also, folgende Sache ist nämlich passiert. Ihr wisst alle, was meine spezielle Fähigkeit ist. Mein Name ist Stefan, nicht umsonst Stefan-Aids-Tietze. Ich kann Aids heilen.
Dankeschön für eure vielen Nachrichten. Es reicht jetzt auch, Dankeschön. Aber es ist wieder mal gelungen. Zum zweiten Mal in der Geschichte der Menschheit ist es gelungen, mit meiner speziellen Genmutation einen Aids-Patienten zu heilen. Aber auch von dir oder von anderen Leuten, die dieselben Mutationen haben? Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Da ich mich nicht erinnere an viele Momente meines Lebens, Es kann sein, dass mich mal jemand irgendwann in so dunkle Ecke gezogen hat und mir Knochenmark entnommen hat. Ich glaube aber nicht. Ich glaube, es ist ohne mein Zutun passiert. Stefan Tietze gehört zu den wenigen Menschen, hat herausgefunden durch eine DNA-Analyse. Du hast ein bestimmtes Gehen, das dafür sorgt, dass du immun bist. Ich habe das CCR5, die CCR5-Mutation und ich bin AIDS-resistent. Und deswegen kann mit meinem Blut, Knochenmark, kann man Menschen heilen. Aber wie viel Knochenmark hast du bis jetzt gespendet? Null. Weißt du warum? Weil die DKMS sagt, den rufen wir an. Vielleicht solltest du die anrufen. Seitdem ich herausgefunden habe, bin ich bei der DKMS angemeldet. Und seitdem kam kein Anruf. Ich bin erschüttert ein bisschen darüber, weil ich denke, hallo, da sitzt jemand, der ist aidresistent, der hat so eine Superkraft. So, und jetzt würde ich gerne bei der DKMS mal anrufen, um zu fragen, was da los ist genau. Menschen sterben, während du hier sitzt und mehr oder weniger deine Zeit verschwendest. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie noch da sind, es ist schon sehr spät. Es ist schon drei Uhr morgens. Ähm, so. Was sind die DKMS? Die deutsche Knochenmark-Spender-Datei. Oh, Knochenmark klingt auch so ekelhaft, sorry, aber eine Knochenmark-Spende, da habe ich vor mir einfach so einen Riesen-Meißel, der direkt in den Rücken stürzt wird. Nee, hör auf, das kann man schon mal machen. Ja. So, 07071. Ich bin froh, dass ich nicht das hin ist. Ich würde das nicht spenden. Also unbedingt anmelden gerne, ihr könnt ja dann immer noch Nein sagen. Aber ihr könnt auch Menschenleben retten. Genau, ich würde auch dich bitten, das zu machen. Ja, mach ich. Ich rufe jetzt mal an und dann erfinden wir mal heraus, was da so los ist und warum die sich nicht bei mir gemeldet haben, sondern ja guten Grund haben. Aber wir müssen schon sagen, dass Sie... Herzlich willkommen bei der DKMS.
Gerne sind wir montags bis freitags in der Zeit von 8 bis 17 Uhr für Sie da.
Was? Wir haben nicht um halb neun abends offen?
Bitte nennen Sie uns dazu nach dem Signalton deutlich Ihre Namen, Ihre Telefonnummer und Ihr Anliegen.
Wir rufen Sie gerne zurück. Vielen Dank und auf Wiederhören. Tietze hallo, schönen guten Tag. Ja, Tietze, Sie haben es schon richtig gehört. Ich denke, dass Sie von mir gehört haben werden, weil ich habe mich ja vor einiger Zeit bei Ihnen angemeldet als Knochenmarkspender. Ich bin der mit der CCR5-Genmutation. Heißt, ich bin ja Aidsresistent und Menschen können, habe ich ja jetzt wieder erfahren in den Medien, mit meinem Knochenmark gerettet werden. Da gibt es ja auch den Berlin-Patienten zum Beispiel, das war ja der erste der Menschheit bekannte Fall. Und jetzt wollte ich einfach mal nachfragen, warum sie nicht anrufen, weil bislang hat sich noch niemand gemeldet. Ich bin bereit, Knochenmark zu spenden. Also ich bin wirklich bereit, eine Menge Knochenmark zu spenden. Und bislang, also ich weiß nicht, wie viel da überhaupt möglich ist. Nicht, dass es mich selber gesundheitlich einstreckt, fände ich gut. Ich bin auch, hören Sie gerade selber ein bisschen krank. Also, kein Aids aber. Ist kein Aids. Also, ich verstehe auch nicht, warum ich Aids-resistent bin, aber Schlupfen bekommen kann, finde ich auch nach wie vor ein ein bisschen seltsam. Aber lassen Sie sich davon nicht abschrecken, ich bin prinzipiell kerngesund und gerne bereit zu helfen. Wäre schön, wenn Sie sich melden könnten, mein Name ist Stefan Tietze und meine Nummer haben Sie ja jetzt. Also, warte ich auf Ihren Anruf, das wäre... Wann hast du Zeit, den Anruf entgegenzunehmen? Sie können sich immer bei mir melden.
Ich mache das Handy meistens im Nichtstören-Modus nachts,
aber Sie können sich melden.
Nur damit Sie Bescheid wissen, Sie können sich melden.
Dankeschön, tschüss.
So, ich glaub, das hat gesessen.
Ich glaub, die werden sich mal richtig an die Karaffe greifen
und sagen, was ist da bis jetzt falsch gelaufen,
wer hatte bis jetzt die Arkte-Tieze.
Ich seh ja, du sammelst seit Wochen Knochenmark. Du hast zu Hause einen ganzen Schuhkarton voller Knochenmark, weil du endlich damit Leute retten willst und niemand will es. Und ich finde, das ist ein Skandal. Was für ein Aggregatzustand hat Knochenmark? Ist es ein Stück Knochen, ist es Plasma-artiges? Das ist doch das, was Hunde an Knochen mögen, oder? Ein Hund mag ein Knochen und ich habe nie verstanden, warum... Ist Tomate zu Tomatenmark was Knochen zu Knochenmarken? Ich glaube schon, es ist so dreifach konzentriert. Ich habe als Kind in so Cartoons, wo dann so ein Hund auch ein Knochen isst teilweise, nie verstanden, was es soll, bis es irgendwann hieß, die kauen da nur gerne drauf rum. Oh, okay, Stufe zwei meiner Skepsis. Warum? Zähne. Ja, weil da ist Knochenmark drin und die schlüffen das dann raus, wie so ein Dickchen. Nee, ich glaube, die machen ihre Zähne für das Zahnpflege. Als ob Hunde so viel Spaß an Zahnpflege hätten, dass sie sich über den Knochen freuen. Das ist wie wenn du dich über eine Zahnbürste freust. Oh, Zahnbürste. Nee, ich habe mir tatsächlich immer, wenn ich ein Hähnchen gegessen habe, ein halbes Hähnchen, habe ich mir die Knochen auf den Gehwegen hinter meinem Haus geschmissen für die Hunde. Das darfst du nicht machen. Ja, das ist mir dann auch klar geworden, nachdem so ein großer Haufen toter Hunde plötzlich da lag. Eine Spur der Verwüstung durch die Stadt hinter dir. Du musst versuchen, mehr Hunde zu retten. Auch Hunde können Aids kriegen. Du musst Hunde retten, du musst es wieder gut machen. Du musst die Balance wieder aufwiegen, du hast zu viele Hunde auf dem Gewissen. Ich verstehe nicht, warum die mich nicht angerufen haben. Man muss ja auch vorher so ein Wattestäbchen durch seinen Munds pferchen. Und da müssen die ja herausgefunden haben, da muss ja so eine Lampe angehen eigentlich, CCR5-Patient. Gibt es nicht auch eine Folge Batman, wo einfach die Lampe nicht angeht und er so zu Hause rumsitzt und dann so ein bisschen Tischtennis gegen sich. So fühle ich mich auch gerade. Und hier kommt die Lampe und dann denkt sich, ey Leute, Batcave, Batmobil, alles am Start. Mein Name ist Stefan Tietze. Guckt mal so, geht die Lampe noch? Ja, die Lampe geht. Okay, ja dann. Ich hab Zeit, ne? Geht auch mal abends so zu der Lampe, macht die mal an und aus. Nur mal zu checken, ob die da an und das geht. wunderbar. Gordon, Sie sind dabei, ja, alles da. Jederzeit, ne, ich bin hier und... Ja, klar, nee, wir wissen nicht bescheid. Passt und stellt sich dann was vom Innen da schön und dann... Hi, ist Batman, ich hätte gern einmal die 51. Ja, und wieder mit doppelt Nahen und Reiter und Reis. Ja. Wieder in die Batcave? Ja. Alles klar.
Batcave eins.
Ja, genau, wir kennen den Eingang.
Alles klar.
Wunderbar, bis gleich.
Nur wie gesagt, falls ich nicht sofort antworte, einfach nochmal klängeln.
Genau, gut, alles klar.
Und dann wie gesagt, ne, dich durch die erste Tür, dann durch die zweite Tür.
Grosse Ben & Jerry's.
Die Code haben sie noch für die zweite Tür.
Richtig, es ist immer noch eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Ja, gut.
Das stimmt.
Gut, dann muss ich unbedingt den Ton machen. Ja, das wäre gut. Ciao. Tschüss. Wann warst du so jetzt mal richtig krank? Oh, es ist schon eine Weile her, aber ich bin nie so ganz krank, weil ich merke immer, wenn ich zu krank werde, dann habe ich keinen Bock mehr drauf und dann versuche ich meinen Körper auszutricksen, dass jetzt irgendwas Schlimmes bevorsteht und ich auf keinen Fall krank sein darf. So, morgen ist Mammutjagd, so, morgen ist Mammutjagd und mein Körper checkt, ja, passt, morgen ist Mammutjagd, da kränkle ich heute noch so ein bisschen rum, aber morgen ist ja Mammutjagd, da kannst du nicht krank sein, weil sonst dein Stamm verhungert, also bist du morgen wieder gesund. Ich heile das rein durch Placebo, einfach durch dieine Gedankenkraft. Ja, dann fällt dein Körper nicht auf, du hast weder Stamm. Nee, der vergisst das. Selbst in der Metapher macht das keinen Sinn, weil niemand braucht dich, niemand ist auf dich angewiesen. Ich bin klüger als mein Körper und mein Körper checkt das nicht, den kann ich so oft es geht, so oft ich will belügen, ich kann einfach sagen, morgen habe ich einen wichtigen Auftritt, ich darf auf gar keinen Fall krank sein. Und dann sage ich halt, ja, der Auftritt wurde abgesagt. Und dann sagt der Körper, ja, kann ich ja schlicht jetzt wieder krank werden. Dann sage ich, ja, ganz genau. Und der Körper so, oh, you got me, you got me. Und das funktioniert jedes einzelne Mal. Oh, der Körper ist so dumm, ne, Körper sind so dämlich. Ich hatte, glaube ich, Glück, dass ich einfach einen sehr, sehr dummen und naiven Körper bekommen habe.
Ich finde interessant, wie sehr du Körper und Geist gerade trennst.
Ja.
Sind es für dich zwei verschiedene Dinge oder ist dein Körper, bist dein Körper nicht du?
In der Hinsicht auf jeden Fall.
Aber sagst du, redest du von dir und deinem Körper oder redest du von dir?
Nee, ich rede von mir.
Ich trenne das nämlich gar nicht bei mir.
Ich trenne das total.
Ja?
So ein Fuss hat mit mir nichts zu tun.
Nee, aber es gibt ja tatsächlich das philosophische Modell, das klar zu trennen und sozusagen die Hülle und Geist von uns geschieden zu betrachten. Ja, das interessiert mich nicht. Körper ist einfach nur. Körper ist Körper und du ist du. Körper ist Körper, du kannst deinen Fuss abschneiden und so einen Roboterfuss und dann ist das halt das eine wie das andere. Aber so arme! Ich bin jetzt zum ersten Mal das Gefühl, ich bin zu dünn jetzt wieder und ich merke wieder, warum es mir mal nicht daran lag, dünn zu sein. Ja. Und warum es mir auch nicht daran lag, sportlich zu sein. Trichterbrust. Meine massiv... Scheiße, die Trichterbrust kommt zurück. Also es gibt noch die Möglichkeit, das zu operieren, aber an alle Leute mit einer Trichterbrust da draußen, lass uns das nicht machen. Lass uns das nicht aufoktudieren lassen von der Gesellschaft, wie eine Brust auszusehen hat. Unsere Brust sieht merkwürdig eingefallen aus. Fuck it, das ist ein Teil von uns. Ich habe jetzt überlegt, das ist einfach ein Teil von mir. Und so laufe ich jetzt dann darum. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ich jemand sein werde, der, selbst wenn ich angenommen irgendwann mal einen gut trainierten Oberkörper hätte, ob ich jemals ein Foto von mir bei Instagram hochladen würde. Erstmal will ich sowieso nicht wissen, wenn ich keinen Trichterbrust hätte, ob ich machen würde. Rein, weil es nicht zu mir passt. Aber ich weiss nicht, ob ich es machen würde, nur nicht wegen der Trichterbrust, weil es schon seltsam ist nach wie vor für mich. Und das ist wirklich der grösste Punkt für die, der grösste OP-Grund ist auch von Ärzten anerkannt, weil es so viel macht mit der Psyche, weil vor allem ja in der Pubertät Leute nicht mit dem Körper sich wohlfühlen, nicht ins Schwimmbad gehen, sich nicht gerne ausziehen und so. Nicht an den Strand gehen. Das habe ich auch, total. Und das ist schon nicht gut. Aber das kommt nur von einem selbst. Ich glaube, da muss man drüber hinwegkommen. Und ich glaube, das ist auch okay. Weil ich glaube, es ist für einen selber schlimmer als für alle anderen. Ich glaube, niemand findet es wirklich wahnsinnig merkwürdig oder ekelig. Es ist einfach ein Teil. Aber was fehlt dann da? Fehlt da dann irgendwas? Das ist dein Brustbein, das geht ja normalerweise klar runter. Und das ist einfach nach hinten geknickt, oder was? Oder fehlt das? Das fällt nach hinten ein. Nach unten hin sinkt das quasi rein. Und was müsste da eigentlich sein, wo das rein sinkt? Das gerade runtergehende Brustbein. Aber du hast schon Herz. Herz ist am Start. Ja, und dadurch gehen die Brust, wie du siehst, die Rippen kommen ein bisschen raus. Unten. Und das ist das Schlimme bei mir. Die Rippen, die rauskommen, das ist hier, siehst du? Das müsste ja eigentlich, wäre das ja so. Ja. Das müsste rauskommen. Das fällt aber ein bisschen rein. Das ist wie so ein kleiner Trichter. Deswegen Trichterbrust. Und das ist wirklich ein Grund, wo ich sage, vielleicht lohnt es sich für mich nicht. Aber gibt es nicht so einen Sweet-Spot, wo du genau viel wiegst, dass man, dass das nicht so zum Vorschein kommt, aber du trotzdem noch nicht dick bist? Ich glaube, man kann sogar auch so Übungen machen dagegen und das so ein bisschen kompensieren. Aber die Rippen zum Beispiel nicht bleiben, die habe ich ja. Das ist ein Teil von mir. Das muss ich akzeptieren. Es hält mir aber schwer. Es gibt diese OP. Ich glaube, es gibt einfach, ab einem gewissen Punkt in deinem Leben muss man sagen, der Körper ist einfach nicht das, womit ich Leute überzeuge. Es ist einfach der gesamte Kosmos Körper, ist nicht mein Trumpf. Ich brauche andere Sachen und sobald man das akzeptiert, läuft es besser, weil man sich denkt, okay, ich habe die Schlacht verloren, aber den Krieg noch nicht. Körper war es einfach. Lebenskrieg. Lebenskrieg habe ich noch nicht verloren. Ich habe noch ein paar Leute in der Reserve und die Körperschlacht habe ich verloren, aber der Rest ist noch zu erobern. Und dann kümmert man sich halt um andere Sachen und versucht auf anderen Dimensionen zu funktionieren. Aber du kennst das ja, wenn du lange in einer Schlacht gekämpft hast, bist du zu schwach für andere Schlachten. Und ich habe jetzt lange an dieser Körperschlacht gekämpft. Und die musst du zurücklassen. Ich bin mir auch bereit, da jetzt bald zu sterben, bei der Körperschlacht. Du kannst nicht perfekt sein, du kannst deine Skillpunkte nicht auf alles setzen. Du musst einfach akzeptieren, dass du Schwächen hast und dann auf andere Sachen setzen. Dann machst du halt dein Klettern oder so. Dann hast du andere Fähigkeiten, wo du sagst, ah, das kann ich gut so angeborene Sachen finde ich es wirklich schlimm. Es ist wirklich schlimm, damit klarzukommen. Weil plötzlich wird dir klar, dass dein Leben so ein bisschen vorherbestimmt ist dadurch. Lustigerweise haben viele Leute in dem Beruf des Autoren Trichterbrüste. Was seltsam ist, weil ich denke... Gut, aber wie heißt es noch mit dem Schauspiel, der Trichterbrust hat? Weiß ich nicht. Irgendein Schauspieler, steht auch in der Puffopedia unter Trichterbrust. Irgendein berühmter Schauspieler. Und der ist berühmter Schauspieler geworden, obwohl er Trichterbrust hatte. Ah, ich glaube hier der Captain America Dude. Chris Evans? Nee. Chris Evans? Ja? Kleine Trichterbrust. Ich glaube, es ist ein kleinerer. Aber ich weiß nicht. Kann schon sein. Nicht Chris Evans? Bei dem haben die doch CGI gemacht, ne? Ja. Also du siehst, das geht alles. Ja, mit CGI. Haben sie beschönigt? Naja, darum geht es doch. Ah nee, die haben nur seinen... Der war muskulös, aber den Kopf haben sie kleiner gemacht. Beim Anfang von Captain America ist der ja ein kleiner Schwächling. Trichterbrust-Schwächling. Und wird dann stärker durch CGI. Nee, aber ich glaube, das Vorherbild war CGI, das nachher nicht. Ach so, ich dachte ja gut, dein Trichterbrust ist perfekt, wird ein Schwächlingsvorherbild. Danach war es CGI, aber zeigt er den Schild an den Trichterbrust. Auch weil der Kameramann so hat auch gelacht beim Filmen. Schön so. Nee, komm, kann man einfach reinstecken? Ich glaube, es ist nicht vorbestimmt. Oh! Wow. Was war das denn? Das sind die Schulz- und Böhmermann-Stühle, die auch in der Sendung kaputt gegangen sind. Echt? Ja. Das ist der zweite Schulz- und Böhmann-Stuhl, der mittlerweile kaputt gegangen ist. Ich glaube, es ist wichtig, was du daraus machst. Du kannst was Gutes draus machen. Tricht der Brust ist, was du draus machst. Ja, es ist am Ende, wo du einfach sagst, okay, ich fokussiere mich auf andere Dinge, ich akzeptiere das. Ich glaube, jeder hat seine Trichterbrust, auch wenn sie vielleicht nicht offensichtlich ist. Jeder hat seine Trichterbrust, das ist gut. Die haben halt einfach super viel Pfand zu Hause rumstehen. Ah, habe ich auch. Und die schämen sich auch für ihre Berge an Pfand. Die fragen sich und fragen auch ihren Podcast-Kollegen dann mal in der Not, ist der nächste Pfandautomat, wo sind Pfandautomaten? Ich weiß nicht, wo mein Pfandautomat ist. Keine Ahnung. Mein ganzer Tisch steht voller Pfandflaschen. Ja. Ich habe so viele Pfandflaschen zu Hause. Ey, für mich die besten Menschen der Welt sind die, die ihre Pfandbillets, also ihre Pfandbons spenden. Weil es gibt für mich kein Befrieden, weil da ist ja nur so Spendenkasten oft daneben, neben den Pfandautomaten, ich sehe du völlig ratloses Gesicht, du hast noch nie Pfand rübergebracht, Pfandautomat und dann kriegst du ja so einen Zettel. Wo macht man das denn? Du kriegst ja so einen Zettli. Wo ist der geheime Ort? Und in Supermärkten und dann kriegst du so einen Zettli und dann kannst du den entweder an der Kasse einlösen gegen Geld oder du spendest ihn. Und ich finde dieses Gefühl so befriedigend, an der Kasse Geld zurückerstattet zu bekommen. Also wenn du halt einen Einkauf machst, dann legst du einen Zettel hin und dann weißt du, es gibt auch Leute, die sind für mich. Es gibt auch Plus in der Rechnung. Es gibt nicht nur Minus an der Rechnung bei der Kasse, es gibt auch einen kleinen Plus dagegen. Und das ist einfach so ein befriedigendes Gefühl, dass ich mein Fundbon niemals spenden würde. Ich spende natürlich anderweitig sehr viel, aber merkt man immer am Jahresende dann so, was man dann immer so das Jahr über für so Daueraufträge angesammelt hat, die dann so, ja einmal im Jahr dann so und so viel Euro und denkst du ja scheiß drauf, das ist ja vergeht. Und am Jahresende merkst du wieder, was, die gibt es noch? Merkst du es am Jahresende? Ja, da kommt dann alles zusammen. Wo kommt da was zusammen? Die ganzen Daueraufträge, die am Jahresende abgebucht werden. Wo du dann keine anderen Spenden hast, irgendwas. So, keine Ahnung, irgendwie keine Ahnung, Aids-Kinder. Und dann merkst du am Jahresende, shit, ey, fuck, das hab ich ja komplett vergesst. Du, Aids-Kinder kann ich dir ja abnehmen. Ja, und die sind jetzt durch dich geheilt eigentlich, von daher kann ich das einstellen. Das kannst du einstellen. Also, komm mal,f von außen und dann draußen, an alle, diese Aids-Spenden, die könnt ihr alle einstellen. Spendet das auf etwas anderes. Andere Krankheit, fokussiert auf Krankheiten, das habe ich jetzt eigentlich gelöst. Oder spendet es an Stefan Tietze, dass er mehr Avocados essen kann, um mehr Knochenmark zu generieren. Oder an die DKMS, damit ich mehr spenden kann. Aber spendet es unter den Bedingungen, dass Stefan Tietze angerufen wird, denn Stefan Tietze, sein Handy muss mal wieder klingeln, sagen wir es so. Haben die mich schon angerufen? Lange, lange nicht mehr geklingelt. Ne, habe ich noch nicht angerufen. Darf sie melden sich? Schaust du jetzt den Rest des Abends immer so verschmilzt und verschämt auf dein Handy? Ich fand den Trick, den man dann macht, dass man denen dann die Nummer einspeichert und dann bei WhatsApp guckt, wann sie das letzte Mal online waren.
Das geht? Du kannst gucken, wann die DKMS, wann die Deutsche Bank das letzte Mal online war?
Klar, die noch bestimmt WhatsApp. Was haben die für ein Bildchen bei WhatsApp? Du kannst doch nicht bei Unternehmen gucken, wann die das letzte Mal online waren.
Nee, ich glaube nicht. Sparkasse war das letzte Mal vor vier Tagen online. Ja, scheiße.
DKMS. So, dann gucken wir, ob die WhatsApp war. Die haben wir doch von WhatsApp. Guck mal. DKMS. Zu WhatsApp einladen. Probier mal... Ah, ich kann sie einladen. Probier WhatsApp mal aus. Tietze hat versucht, sie zu WhatsApp einzuladen. Probier WhatsApp aus, damit chatte und telefoniere ich mit Leuten, die mir wichtig sind. Hol es dir gerade so unter whatsapp.com. Kann man jetzt als SMS an die DKMS schicken? Mach ich mal. Ladet erstmal alle grossen DAX-Unternehmen in Deutschland zu WhatsApp ein. Und Telegram. Ladet sie in die das Podcast-Ufo-Telegram-Gruppe ein, da ist immer viel los. Gucken wir mal, ob sie da sind, DKMS. Online das letzte Mal? Nein, da waren sie nicht. Da kann man sie nicht mal hin einladen. Aber Bildchen haben sie auch nicht? Kein Bildchen. So ein trauriger Smiley, so ein trauriges Bluttropfen. Ich sehe schon, das wird eine sehr toxische Beziehung zwischen dir und der DKMS, wenn man sagt, hier hat man ja eine Nachricht gelesen, aber seit zwei Tagen nicht geantwortet. Was ist da los, soll ich jetzt noch mal nachschreiben warum antwortet sie denn nicht? Und die ist auch so unangenehm, mich mal zurückzurufen. Ja, und irgendwann sagst du, du, pass auf, das mit uns, das wird los. Das wird vielleicht nichts. Niemand schluss mit mir vielleicht. Ja, genau. Der erste Mensch. Du, Stefan, am Anfang hat es irgendwie noch geprickelt und so, aber mittlerweile. Allerdings spüren wir gar nichts mehr, wir haben auch genug Knochenmark. Ja, wir halten ein dreckiges Knochenmark. Am Anfang hat es Spaß gemacht, aber dann wurde es irgendwann, es wurde so Routine mehr. Aber guck mal, das ist doch genau der Ausgleich. Die Trichterbrust ist vielleicht ein Makel, aber dafür hast du perfektes Knochenmark. Gut, von der Sichtbarkeit her... Ich will aber langfristig weg von Makeln. Das ist verliebt. Und deswegen möchte ich nicht mehr, deswegen möchte ich dafür öffentlich plädieren, dass Trichterbrust kein Makel ist. Nee, und du kannst ja tatsächlich Vorsteher der Trichterbrust geben, Herr Hase, die Trichterjungs und Mädchen. Ich gründe vielleicht Trichterjungs e.V. Ja, und du kannst dann einfach in der Öffentlichkeit so ein bisschen besser darstellen. Nee, ich bin dafür, dass wir alle, und ich nehme mich da mal raus jetzt, aber alle TrichterbrustjJungs machen ein selbstbewusstes Instagram-Oberkörper-Freifoto.
Ja, wie sie so Cornflakes in ihrer Trichterbrust essen.
Ausfindlich ist es schlecht, ja genau. Oder so Strohalm-Cola raus trinken abends, beim schönen DVD-Arm.
Oder so Kleingeld, einfach Schlüssel reinbringen. Oder die ganze Freundin, oder Mallorca am Strand und alle Freunde sozusagen Ria aus der Trichterbrust trinken.
Ah, oder so Golfspielen und man muss in die Trichterbrust treffen am Strand.
Das ist gefährlich.
Das ist sehr, sehr gefährlich.
Nicht machen.
Ja.
Nicht niemals in die Trichterbrust golfen.
Vielen Dank. Oder so ein Golfspielen und man muss in die Trichterbrust treffen am Strand. Das ist gefährlich. Das ist sehr, sehr gefährlich. Nicht machen.
Ich spreche aus eigener Erfahrung, schmerzhaft.
Da gab es einen Golfspieler, der hat einen Putt auf dem Green und dann nur noch ungefähr zwei Meter.
Easy macht man rein und dann puttet er halt den Ball und während der Ball rollt, wird so ein Blatt angeweht
und das Blatt trifft genau den Golfball und legt den Golfball ab. Und dieser Blick von dem so, Leute, auch so ein ratloser Blick zum Schiedsrichter, so, äh, hallo, Blatt? Und der Schiedsrichter... Oh, das Blatt so ein ratloser, so ein Sorry, sorry, sorry. Ich, war ich das? Aber er ist einfach scheiße. Und der Schiedsrichter auch so, ich musste noch nie eingreifen, ich weiß nicht. Er auch so, Herr Golf ist in seinem einseitigen Regelbuch nach, so ein Flyer, den er in der Hand bekommen hat. Und wenn der Golf ins Loch geht, ist es still vorbei. Man kann manchmal schon richtig Pech haben. Ja, da muss man aber auch einsehen, dass man einfach die falsche Sportler gewählt hat vielleicht. Jetzt kann ich sehr gute Netflix-Doku-Reihe empfehlen. Netflix-Doku-Reihe, ich glaube, Losers heißt sie oder so was, sollte man finden, ist recht neu, wo es um Athleten gibt, die verloren haben. Und immer sehr, sehr interessante kleine Mini-Dokus. Haben mehr Athleten verloren als gewonnen? Wahrscheinlich schon. Man kennt ja die Geschichten von den grossen Gewinnern, die sich durchsetzen gegen alle Schwierigkeiten, aber es gibt halt auch richtig viele, die einfach nicht gewonnen haben. Als ich eine ganze Zeit krank war, habe ich Sport geguckt, Langlauf und Abfahrt, so eine Abfahrt, so eine Abfahrt, Skiabfahrt auf Freiburg. Abfahrtkram. Und die meisten haben diese eine Kurve nicht geschafft, was mich sehr amüsiert hat, in so einem kranken Zustand. Da krieg ich mir, die kriegen wir auch nicht hin. Die sind so brutal steil, diese Skiabfahrt. Man checkt, als Zuschauer versteht man in der Regel nicht mal den Ansatz, wie schwer das ist, was die Athleten da machen. Es sieht viel langsamer aus, ich weiß nicht warum, aber auch die Steilheit von dem Hang lässt sich nicht übertragen in der Kamera. Es lässt sich überhaupt nicht, weil du kannst ja, der Winkel ist immer irgendwie weird und du hast kein Verständnis. Es müsste darunter in so grossen Lettern das ist fucking steil. Das ist fucking steil. Und du denkst halt, du siehst ein Bild und kombinierst das ja mit deinen eigenen Erfahrungen. Und du siehst einen Abhang, Skiabhang und denkst, das wird ja so steil sein. Das Gefühl für Steilheit entwickelt sich halt auch um deine Surroundings und um dein, vor allem deine Schwerkraftgefühl. Ja, ja. Und ich war mal auf so einer Skipiste, als so eine Abfahrt war, irgendwie so ein großes Turnier. Und ich habe mich nicht mehr im Ansatz getraut. Das ist ja super eisig und auch das ist ja alles super krass. Und man muss wirklich eigentlich ständig alle fünf Sekunden, müsste der Kommentator erwähnen, oh, sehr schöner Sprung hier auf dieser extrem steilen Bahn, die fucking steil ist. Alter Vater ist das steil. Holy moly ist die gerade schnell, das kommt nicht rüber, aber wow. Die waren das Gegenteil davon, die waren die ganze Zeit sehr skeptisch. So, heute ist noch niemand richtig gut gefahren. Und man sagt, die sind doch alle sehr, sehr gut gefahren. Ihr habt zu höhere Ansprüche. Ja, vielleicht schreiben die immer die Ansprüche ein bisschen runter. Die erwartet zu viel. Vielleicht geben die den ersten zehn erst mal direkt den ersten Platz. Und danach, die kriegen dann die ersten drei. Ist aber auch nicht schlecht, so ein unbeeindruckender Kommentator und jetzt hat er den Ball und immer wieder hat er den Ball. Trüben rüber auf die linke Seite, Verteidiger kriegt sich und wow, schön reingerollt. Toll, toll, ganz toll, wow, wow. Ach, richtig gut, was läuft sonst doch so, Arte, ah, der Doku. Guck nebenbei einen Film und muss manchmal lachen über die Gags. Ist das hier? Ende Saison für Sie, ich habe kein Problem hier. Und was ist jetzt im Aus? Och Gott, meine Güte. Und jetzt der Ball hat keine Luft mehr. Jetzt kommt der Luftpumpenmeister hier und hat die Luftpumpe. Ja, ich komme gleich, sollte bald durch sein. Telefoniert beim Kommentieren. Ja, kommentiert noch ein anderes Spiel dabei. Ja, nee, nee, ich bin nicht gleich durch. Nee, nee, nee. Ah, die kicken. Nee, auf drei. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Begleicht zurück. Ciao. Richtig auch. Ciao, du ciao, ciao. War's gut. Hast du, was heißt da eine Verabschiedung? Du sagst ciao, oder? Ciao, ciao. Ciao, ciao? Ich mag es nicht.-tschau. Baba, so wie Baba. Haben wir in Wien gelernt? Das hast du zu häufig gesagt in Wien. Unangenehm häufig. Warum? Aber das macht so viel Spaß. Baba, das klingt einfach so, es ist ein herzlicher Abschied. Ja, das hast du zu häufig gemacht. Da wollte ich ein bisschen anbiedern. Und das fand ich auch gut bei Österreichern, wenn sie dann so sagen, so man sagt was und sie widersprechen, also wo der Deutsche
würde sagen würde, doch, sagt der Österreicher, oh ja, und das fand ich immer so gut. Na oh ja, das stimmt schon, oh ja, das finde ich so gut, das ist, da verrät sich jeder Österreicher, dieses na oh ja, oh ja, na das ist Das ist urleiwäumt, finde ich. Das ist urleiwäumt. Grossartig. Es war eine tolle Stadt, lieft.
Ziehen wir nach Wien irgendwann? Ich habe echt Bock, nach Wien zu ziehen. Lass uns doch so eine kleine Miniewohnung in Wien teilen. Von der Miete her. Ja, dein scheiß Pfand, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Da kommst du ab und zu und bringe den Pfand weg. Und darf das Belay? Da haben wir das Belay an der Kasse ab. Genau, ja. Ja, ne, dann würde ich gerne ab und zu mal ein Wochenende verbringen. Du kannst ja auch mal, da muss man es aufteilen. Machen wir so ein Google Docs auf, oder dann trage ich mal Sperrtage ein, wo ich da bin. Ja, und dann lässt du dein Müll liegen. Und die gebrauchten Kondome liegen. Ich war ja da in der, habe ich noch gar nicht erzählt, aber ich war vor einem Monat ungefähr ein paar Tage da, habe ich mal erzählt, oder? Da war ich jedenfalls in der Wiener Staatsoper, das war ganz toll.
Da kam neben mir der Herr, war sehr spät dran, kam zu spät, um sich dann neben mich hinzusetzen und den Rest des Stückes zu schlafen.
Die ganze Zeit geschlafen. Oh, oh, oh, shit, shit, shit, ich muss schnell schnell, fährt über die Straße und schreit die Treppe hoch und dann.
Ja, aber allein dieser Aufwand und diese Hektik, die mit, Zum Opfernbesuch gehen ist ja Arbeit. Also, da gehört ja was dazu. Hinzufahren, sich schönzumachen, hinzugelangen, dann Sachen an der Gedrobe abzugeben. Und dann sich hinzusetzen, um zu spät und dann zu beschliessen, ich schlafe jetzt den Rest des Stückes und lasse den Schlaf zu. Man kennt die Kämpfer, man kennt die Kämpfer, man kennt die Kämpfer, wo man das Zucken noch hat und das, nee.
Oder wo die Frau dann daneben, man da so boxen muss.
Nee, da kann man leider. Und dann dieses Aufrichten nochmal und dieses, ich versuche nochmal, mich anders hinzusetzen, um nicht einzuschlafen.
Er hat nicht gekämpft, er hat gepennt.
Er hatte die Mütze auf, er hatte die Schlafbrille auf.
Das war mir fast echt unangenehm gegenüber Richard Wagner.
Ja, das muss man dem nicht antun, dem herzensguten Menschen. Nee, ich finde, das ist die Grenze. Wirklich, da sollte man wirklich nicht. Ich war tatsächlich letztens auch in einem Konzert und ich bin ja extrem empfindlich, so was so, Reden im Kino und Störungen und so. Ich hasse das und ich bin da einfach überempfindlich, glaube ich. Aber in dem Konzert habe ich jemanden gesehen und da dachte ich mir wirklich, wow, und zwar während, also es war ein Klavierkonzert, also eine Pianistin alleine, er hat gespielt und der musste anscheinend während eines Stücks raus und er hat seine Schuhe ausgezogen, hatte die Schuhe in der Hand genommen und ist dann auf Socken aus dem Saal rausgeschlichen, Wo ich mir dachte, wow! Das hat er nicht zum ersten Mal gemacht. Nee, das hat er nicht. Ich bin wirklich aufgestanden und habe applaudiert, weil ich mir dachte, Alter, du machst das richtig! Du hast einfach Respekt für das Stück. Boah, der Pianist aufgehört hat zum Spiel gesagt hat, geile Aktion, dankeschön nochmal. Geile Nummer, geil, einmal Applaus, jetzt mal alle, alle, nee, erst mal, das finde ich schon krass, weil normalerweise... Und er hat einen Applaus, aber noch langsam rausgekommen. Ja, hat seine Schuhe ausgezogen und mit den Schuhen in der Hand ist er rausgeschlichen und an der Tür der Portier macht ihm langsam die Tür auf und er geht raus. Wo ich mir einfach dachte, genau diese Art von Respekt erwarte ich von jedem hier im Raum. Natürlich auch wieder Handy angelassen und Bullshit und Idioten. Das wäre so lustig, wenn bei dem Typen das Handy geht, wenn er im Gang dich schleicht auf leisen Sohlen. Was ich noch sagen wollte, der Typ neben mir kam dann, hat den Rest des Stücks gepennt, ist vom Applaus am Ende, es war ein Stück ohne Pausen, ist am Ende aufgeweckt worden vom Applaus
und ist der Erste gewesen, der für die Standing-Oberation aufgestanden ist.
Ich dachte mir, das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Jemand, der für den Applaus kommt, offensichtlich, das war sein Ding.
Und der ist lange geblieben.
Das hat mich schlecht gewundert, offensichtlich ist das Publikum sehr anspruchsvoll,
aber die sind alle gegangen, schon während des Applauses. Und ich bin bis zum Ende da gewesen und hab geklatscht und der auch. Als einer von wenigen hat er gesagt, ich hab die ganze Zeit gepennt, aber wenn Leute diese eine Würdigung verdient haben, dann erstmal bis zum Ende klatscht. Vielleicht macht ihm das einfach am meisten Spaß, zu applaudieren einfach, der Applaus am Ende macht ja auch Spaß. Dass er sagt, mein Anstand sagt mir, ich muss bis zum Ende da bleiben und klatschen, aber er sagt mir, er bietet mir nicht zu schlafen während des ganzen Stückes. Vielleicht wollte er auch einfach nur sehr lebhafte Träume haben, dass er sagte, ich schlafe einfach nur zu Wagner, einfach um in diese Welt einzutauchen, im Traum. Vielleicht ist es Next Level Musik konsumieren, vielleicht bist du noch nicht so weit. Ich bin echt musikalisch, künstlerisch ganz angetan von Wagner. Total. Auch so sehr, dass ich das Gefühl habe, ich muss mich mit dem Antisemitismus auseinandersetzen. Vielleicht ist da was dran. Nee, um meine Faszination einordnen zu können, glaube ich. Nochmal vielen Dank an das Intro von Florian. Ja, und vielen Dank an die DKMS,
die sich hoffentlich bald meldet.
Mir gibt es erst ein Dankeschön, wenn Sie sich gemeldet haben.
Mit Aufträgen. Ich bin bis jetzt auch sehr dankbar für Ihre Arbeit.
Ich finde das toll.
Wir haben in Wien leider vergessen, abzuheben.
Das heißt, heute wieder ein klassisches Doppelabheben.
Ansonsten stecken wir für immer fest.
Macht's gut, bis zur nächsten Folge.